okay so first of all I want to thank the
organized this for letting me talk and
want to apologize because it's something
I've been working on for a while so
probably some of you have seen bits and
pieces of this and so don't fall asleep
during the parts you see I want to say
that this is work that's being done
jointly with Michael and I so student
which on wholesome back and yeah so a
lot of this is joint work so first just
to set the stage quantitative traits I'm
like that I mean traits that vary
continuously in populations obvious
things are like body mass height and of
course the famous Bristol number of
drosophila these can be important in
adaptation for example colorants to low
oxygen tolerance being the trait
obviously in disease for example obesity
is a sort of discretization of a
quantitative trait of body mass or BMI
maybe and obviously an agriculture
things like fruit yield and seed yield
are really important things that people
are interested in optimizing when
they're developing agriculture or
interested in understanding in the wild
riled progenitors of agricultural things
all right so all of this is going to be
sort of in the context of the model
proposed by Fisher way back in the day
when the biome attrition xand the
Mendelian didn't know that they were
talking about the same thing and the
idea here is that you have n by allelic
low sigh um this is the guy work as a
pointer nope there goes okay great right
so you have n by allelic losa impacting
the trait and in this simple additive
model we just say that a lil J at locust
I has some rent some effect on the tray
and then your phenotype is just you sum
up over all the low sigh and all the
alleles at every locus you know you just
take the effect of the allele that you
have at that locus and so what happens
is as you increase the number of low
sigh involved you go from sort of you
know if you have one locus you have
three genotypes so you get this very
patchy phenotype distribution as you
increase the number of low side of five
if you get something that
starting to look pretty normally
distributed and when you get up to a
hundred low sigh you end up getting
something normally distributed and of
course this is sort of a random model
but you can calculate things like the
expected the mean of the mean which has
this form and the mean of the variance
in the population which has this form
but it's important to emphasize that
right these are expectations of means
and expectations of variances and
basically for the rest of this talk I'm
also going to ignore environmental
variability because you can sort of yeah
it's not super interesting for what I'm
going to be talking about so when the
trade evolves of course this genetic
variants changes through time and you
can show pretty easily that under a
reasonable sort of wide range of
reasonable models at equilibrium the
genetic variation is given by twice the
population size times the mutational
input and what is meant by the
mutational input is how many mutations
you get per individual per generation so
you get if you have a mutation rate of
mu and each person is diploid so you
have two chromosomes you get two new
mutations per individual per generation
and each mutation you imagine draws its
effect from a distribution with variance
Sigma squared so that's how you get this
equilibrium variance but of course this
is again the expected variance at
equilibrium and Lynch in Hill in 86
calculated the variance of the variance
that equilibrium motivated in some in
part by this equilibrium variance result
landy has this very influential model of
quantitative trade evolution as a
Brownian motion and in this case this is
obviously an approximation of the full
model in that we're not keeping track of
individual low sigh and were critically
assuming genetic variance is constant in
time and sort of along with that we're
assuming that mutations have sort of
very small effects where in this
infinitesimal model where you have many
mutations of very small effects it seems
pretty reasonable that this gives you a
Brownian motion kind of thing and landy
also showed that you can use an
orenstein uhlenbeck model to model
stabilizing selection in this regime and
of course this has been extremely
influential in
comparative biology felsenstein with the
independent contrast models really sort
of said that when you're looking at
continuous traits in comparative data
you better be having some model of trade
evolution in mind or you're going to
make the wrong inferences but while
people have been using the Brownian
model for a long time I think that we're
starting to see that there's evidence
for non Brownian evolution from
comparative data so this on the left
here is a figure from a paper by yet and
colleagues from a couple years ago where
they basically on the x-axis is a time
between two species like the the
phylogenetic distance between two
species and on the y-axis is the
phenotypic difference between the
species and they basically argued well
look what you have is like almost no
change for about million years and then
suddenly an explosion of change after
that they call this a blunderbuss
pattern because it was kind of like a
blunderbuss I guess but they said that
well what's really going on is you're
waiting for macro evolutionary changes
to happen and then suddenly there's a
big burst of change sort of in a jump
like fashion along those same lines this
is a figure from a paper by Michael
Landes and myself and Mason leang where
we were we developed some models of
continuous trade evolution inference
strategies for these models that you can
apply to comparative data and what
basically you can think of this x-axis
is a parameter that specifies
non-gaussian addey the Y then this is a
posterior density of that parameter the
solid line is the posterior density as
inferred from primate data set and the
dashed line is sort of a bootstrap
posterior density where we simulated
data assuming that there was no no large
effect mutation so you can see is those
pretty strong support here for non
non-gaussian ad where the Gaussian guy
would have a mode it to
so we thought about this and of course
both Yetta and ourselves invoke some
sort of selective explanation for these
non-gaussian ities what we thought well
maybe let's go back to a neutral model
and see if we can invoke some of this
stuff from a neutral model and so the
model that I'm going to talk about is
haploid instead of diploid because it
makes all the calculations much easier
as always we're going to have a trait
governed by n low sigh each locus is
independent so we're assuming that there
is no there's free recombination between
low sides that impact the trait and we
have a constant mutation rate and also
every locus draws its effect from an
effect size distribution with density p
of y so this is sort of this is just an
example of the model so here's a to
locust model we have a sample of size
five from the population we just without
loss of generality say the root is zero
the root phenotype of each locus is zero
and then here you have a mutation that
draws an effect that makes you point to
whatever units bigger in your
quantitative trait so you trace that
down you can see that all of these three
individuals have phenotype that's point
to this individual ease to individuals
got an ancestral mutation that made it
point three or minus point three and so
they're minus point three you do the
same thing at this other one and then to
get the ultimate phenotype of each
individual you add across lo sai right
so point 2 plus 0 is point 2 and so on
and so forth so that's the model there's
any questions this would probably be a
good time to clarify yeah you said the
schedule for your trays in what sense so
you normalize some
yeah so the scale will I think in my
answer so well I guess to say so the the
the mutations are drawn from some effect
distribution and I'm going to need that
to behave nicely to calculate things
maybe that will and you'll see that yeah
yeah no selection we wanted to try to
get some non-gaussian ax t in a lot of
sex both side together yeah in in the
end I'm going to be talking about a lot
of such low side so as was just brought
up there's this question of what are
mutations what that's like so the common
model is this infinitesimally so this is
a figure that I asked it's someone to
point it to me on Twitter and Twitter
helped so that was very nice what this
is basically showing is some human
height g was-- genome-wide Association
study results of basically showing that
as you increase the number of plus
alleles that an individual has you also
increase their height and the increases
are basically small the sort of the take
home from this figure in real data the
increases in height / + allele are very
small this is a figure from another
paper where they tried to estimate the
distribution of effects from various G
wasps hits and basically again what you
can see is that the vast majority of g
wasps hits or excuse me not even gos
hits but this is sort of supposed to be
the inferred distribution of effects
across all causative lo sai are very
small so in quickly tail out so that's
sort of the traditional model that you
get but there's some cases where you
might expect there to be large effect
mutation so this is a figure from a
paper out of tricia wit cops group or
what they did is they basically label
the yeast protein with yellow
fluorescent protein um made a shitload
of mutations and asked how much does the
expression level change so the
expression level of this gene the amount
of yellow fluorescence that it produced
was the phenotype and for various
classes of mutations you can see that
they actually got some very large effect
me too
for example some that reduced normalized
expression by a minus 38 whatever units
these are so you can see that in these
cases it's pretty reasonable to think
you might get large effect mutations for
example by disrupting a transcription
factor binding site or for example
getting a null mutation in an upstream
pathway where you sort of knock out
everything downstream and hence no
longer express the gene to do some
calculations in this case since I'm
doing a lot of stuff with sums of random
variables it's not going to be very
useful to work in the phenotype space so
instead I'm going to work using
characteristic functions and just to
remind you what the characteristic
function is it's the expectation of this
thing where I is the imaginary unit a
square root of minus 1 and you sort of
right you just compute this expectation
and the reason this is helpful is
because if I have a random variable
that's a sum of a bunch of independent
random variables as I basically do here
then I can just compute the
characteristic function of that sum by
multiplying across my random variables
and if you were you noticed when I
described my mutational model you
basically have given the coalescent tree
the mutational processes the compound
poisson process along the tree what I
mean by that is you have any hits of a
rate lambda plus on process and then
your trait at the end of it is just the
sum of random random increments of NT
random increments right so this is a
compound poisson process you wait you
jump you wait you jump you wait you jump
it's easy to show that the
characteristic function of a compound
poisson process is this thing we're here
so this is the characteristic function
of the compound poisson process and this
side is the characteristic function of
the jump colonel so it sort of is the
characteristic function of the y i's in
this case
so let's try to do some calculations in
this case the simplest one is for a
sample of size 2 and I apologize for my
ms paint figures what you have here is
if you condition on this sample on the
the coalescence time of these two
individuals it's easy to calculate this
because you sort of have a compound
poisson process going this way a
compound poisson process going this way
and then i'll explain a bit more
thoroughly later is that it's actually
going to be better to compute the
difference in phenotype of these two
rather than sort of the joint density of
X 1 and X 2 because that's going to end
up depending on the route and that's
sort of not something we want to really
care about so how do you do this right
you calculate the characteristic
function conditioned on the the
coalescence time which has this density
u minus T standard coalescent theory
crank through some stuff and you get
some some calculation right and what's
kind of cool about this is this is
basically general for any mutation
effect distribution at one locus because
I've assumed essentially nothing besides
that the characteristic function exists
which it always does if this is if the
mutation of that kernel is a probability
measure so yeah like I said there's this
issue with the phenotype at the root and
basically it's easy to see in pictures
if you didn't think about it already
which is that if I'm starting with this
sample of size 4 and now I say well I
want to make a sample of size five I
should be able to do that in a sort of
consistent way and I obviously can in
this case but it might be the case that
my fifth sample and two ends up
coalescing more anciently than the root
in which case the root is no longer 0
which I tried to do to make compu
computations easy it's actually some
other number X that you might need to
that you need to figure out how to
consistently set so there's going to be
a distribution on this trait value that
won't get 0 here this seemed to to
complicate it I don't want to deal with
that so instead I just normalized out
the route by saying if I have n
expression level excuse me and
individuals in my population x0 to xn
minus 1 I can just
reduce my sample size by one and instead
of considering x 0 x and minus 1 i'll
consider the Z's which are defined as
the difference of each individual with x
0 so now since all of these differences
basically pass through the roots so now
if I'm looking at these two I have to go
all the way up to the root and I
basically SAT subtract out the root so I
don't need to worry about it anymore and
using this approach with a little bit
you can do the same characteristic
function calculation it becomes a lot
more tedious for a sample of size 3 and
you have something and here I've assumed
that the mutation Colonel symmetric and
that's what I'm going to assume for the
rest of this so okay this sucks like
doing these calculations sucks I don't
want to keep doing it can I do something
do something that makes this a little
bit easier so I'm going to take this
limit of the number of low side getting
large and of course you can do this in
sort of dumb ways and get either sort of
a uniform distribution on our as your
traits which is obviously not what you
want or you can do it in some other ways
and get sort of point masses which is
again not really interesting in order to
do this we need to decrease the effect
size of each locus or the mutation rate
at each locus in such a way that we get
something non trivial in the limit and
I'm going to tell you about three
non-trivial limits two of which are very
similar and one of which I will ignore
but this one this first one is when the
mutation rate per locus decreases then
the next to our when the effect size for
locus decreases are moving into the
infinitesimal range but the difference
here being whether or not there are
mutations of large effect so if you take
this decreasing mutation rate approach
where basically what you have is that
the product of the number of low sigh
and the mutation rate per locus stays
constant you end up getting you can take
this limit in the sample of size 3 and
get what looks to me to be the sort of
the the characteristic function of a
coral of two correlated compound poisson
processes not totally sure how else to
interpret that
but I don't think I'm but I'm not going
to talk about this much more because I
don't think this is really biologically
relevant I think really what we think is
not that as you get more and more low
sigh you get more mutations become rare
and rare so I'm going to ignore this one
and instead focus more on the classical
sort of infinitesimally so if you fail
to have large effect mutations if you're
mutational Colonel does not have fat
tails or is not power law then you get
unsurprisingly a Gaussian limit so you
take you you get this compound parameter
that is the product of the number of low
sigh and the variance per locus your
characteristic function for the sample
size converges to this thing which can
be recognized as the bivariate Gaussian
distribution with this variance
covariance matrix so this seems nice if
you have in stead fat tail so your
density has tails that look like this
for alpha less than 2 this is the sort
of standard power law this is what it
means to have a power law you redefine
some parameters and you take your limit
again you get something here that is the
characteristic function of a bivariate
alpha stable distribution no the problem
is unlike Gaussian distributions where
they're sort of one thing that is a
multivariate Gaussian distribution so
you always are just specified by a
variance covariance matrix there's sort
of a lot of things that are multivariate
stable distributions and this will come
back to bite me in a little bit so a
nice thing here is as we know the the
lineages from a coalescent are
exchangeable and when we know about
exchangeable things is d phonetics
theorem which says that if I have an
infinitely exchangeable random vector
then I can compute the probability
density of a subsample of that random
vector as a mixture over iid probability
densities that is this here this product
in here is just the probability of x1 xn
given some random probably given a
probability
and then I need to integrate over these
probability measures so that's what the
phonetics theorem tells us and it says
well since my coalescent limits aren't
my coalescent lineages are exchangeable
can i use the phonetics theorem to do
something interesting and in the normal
case you can and it's sort of a more
general assault that a about
multivariate normal distributions with
sOMEC with black very nicely behaved
variance covariance matrices but
basically the guess is that then given
the mean value of the trait the trade is
distributed as a normal distribution
with sorry that should be mean m and
variance theta over 2 Sigma squared and
then the mean itself is random with
variance with as a normal dish normally
distributed random variable with mean 0
and the same variance so if you compute
the random the variance of X using the
law of total variance you get the same
equilibrium variance as you compute it
as I showed you earlier that's computed
using sort of recursion approaches and
this is sort of a proof that this ends
up working so that leads to a tempting
interpretation and a conjecture which is
that if you condition on the amount of
evolution exclusive to the sample that
you're normalizing to that's basically
the mean right everyone has to be
subtracted from the amount of evolution
on along this lineage that you've
normalized against and then you
basically integrate and then basically
in in the limit here every sample or
excuse me each sample is the first
sample that coalesce is with that sample
at some point so you basically integrate
over the coalescence time of your given
sample and that one that you're
normalizing it gets so this
interpretation seems to say that you can
get a very nice thing instead of having
to worry about multivariate gaussians
you have this quite simple mixture story
where the limit distribution is normal
with variance theta over 2 Sigma squared
and a random me
mean and this is nice if you want to
apply this to some data so we tested
this we could not figure out how to
prove this if for general sample sizes
but we tested this by doing simulations
so we simulated the coalescent model I
describe what you're seeing here along
the x-axis is the number of low sigh
along the y-axis is the number of
samples and this is a heat map of the
kolmogorov-smirnov DC test so basically
when it's this color that means that the
D is very small these look like the same
distribution when it's this color they
look different and you can see that as
the number of losa increases you
actually do end up converging sort of
you get you converge to the limiting
distribution at least in simulations so
we thought great this worked for the
normal case does this work in the case
where you have power law of mutations
and so we made basically this is
essentially the the mirror conjecture in
the power law case and we tried to do
the same simulations and you can see
it's not as impressive as before in some
sense so whereas before we got basically
all the way down into the zero there was
no difference when we have a large
number of samples and a large number of
low side here it's not seeming to
converge that fast and we thought well
is this just telling us that the
convergence is slower or is it telling
us that the conjecture is wrong so we
simulated we had simulated data to do
this and we just looked the simulated
data and what I'm showing here is
something like 10 density estimates of
the quantitative trait from the
simulations the black line which you can
barely see is what you would predict
from the conjecture and the other lines
are random sample are random instances
of the the simulations and what you can
see is basically none of them look like
what you predict from the conjecture
right there's sort of more randomness
than expected you get some things that
are somehow wider some things that are
somehow skinnier so it seems like in the
Alpha stable case in the case where you
have power laws this conjecture doesn't
hold so for a long time we
well we must be doing our simulations
wrong so I sucked it up into a horrible
calculation for a sample of size 4 where
there's 18 trees and it's not a very
pleasant thing to calculate but in the
end basically for the conjecture to hold
this is what we would need the the
characteristic function in this limit to
look like because you sort of this this
part comes from the random mean or
random median and this part comes from
the independence but actually the
characteristic function looks like this
so we have this part in this part but we
also get this sort of extra core sort of
extra correlation where you have
pairwise correlations correlations not
quite the right word since it doesn't
exist but these pairwise dependencies
that couldn't be there for this
conjecture to hold so that's led us to a
very weak conjecture which is that the
limit distribution is alpha stable with
some random parameters we don't know
what they are and I'm not honestly even
sure that this is right I think there
might be the fact that you get this sort
of pairwise thing and probably as you go
to larger sample sizes you get sort of
three wise for why is 51 makes me think
that actually it might be a mixture of
district stable distributions and I
cannot get anywhere with this so if
someone has any thoughts that would be
awesome to hear but taking this
conjecture we decided okay let's see
what we can find an empirical data so we
looked at RNA seek data so gene
expression data from a fungus called me
Ross Perot krasa comes from this pretty
sweet paper by Chris Ellison has a
postdoc with Doris back Trog from a
couple years ago and we restricted to
our genes with fpk I'm greater than 1 if
you're not familiar with gene expression
stuff this basically means me strictly
to genes whose expression levels look
like they're more than noise and what we
did is for each gene we fit a normal
distribution and an alpha stable
distribution and then we asked we
performed a likelihood ratio test so the
normal distribution is an alpha stable
distribution with alpha equals 2 so
tested this null hypothesis alpha equals
2 vs type offices that alpha is less
than 2 and that's what we thought we did
basically actually we didn't do it right
and I didn't have time before this to
fix that up but we did have some
analysis for a few genes I think that
this is probably not these results are
not final but they're relatively close
to what you would expect when we don't
have typos in our code so the
distribution of p-values is the first
thing i want to show you so this is one
of those cases where you don't expect
your p-values too because quare
distribute sorry not you p values but
your likelihood ratio test a stick
should not be chi square distributed
because you have your null hypothesis on
the boundary of your parameter space so
you get a lot of people use that are
basically the the inferred parameter was
on the boundary of the parameter space
so that's what's going on here but you
can see that we have sort of in excess
also of low low low p-values suggesting
that there might be something
interesting and in fact 54 of our 300
ish genes are significant with an FDR of
thirty-two percent so maybe you know 30
of these genes are actually real when
you look at the the Alpha so the sort of
the heaviness of the tails and each of
these genes this is the histogram you
get you can see that things are
basically between about 1.4 and 1.8 so
they're not like super duper
heavy-tailed none of these have infinite
mean but of course they all have
infinite variants as oscar mentioned the
other day and then I to convince you we
did something interesting I chaired
picked some examples um so each of these
is a different gene the histogram is the
observed distribution of gene expression
levels in red is the best fitting
Gaussian in black is the best fitting
stable distribution and I have anything
really to say about this besides doesn't
look so bad to me and so that's really
it I think I sort of powered through
that so what we were able to do is
ensure
Jesus coalescing model quantitative
trait evolution this has this sort of
same idea has been used a couple times
in the past but is actually somewhat
rare despite how it seems to be a pretty
powerful way to compute things and it's
you know tedious but straightforward to
calculate these characteristic functions
for arbitrary sample sizes and to try to
make it simpler on us we found these
limiting distributions as the number of
low side became large and we conjectured
about how these limiting distributions
extend this larger samples making use of
defend eddies theorem simple things to
include what makes this model sort of
powerful is it's very easy to include
say samples that are non contemporaneous
by using the serially sampled coalescent
it's easy again to include population
structure doing all of these things does
not really make your job any harder
extending it to diploid seems kind of
tedious but again straightforward
because you just have to calculate for
larger and larger trees every individual
you add adds two more individuals or two
more lineages in your coalescent and so
it's not super fun but so then one of
the criticisms that's often love you
hear is that basically no quantitative
traits evolve neutrally but i think that
there's a couple reasons to study this i
mean obviously gives you some
analytically tractable calculations
which is always fun but i think it does
give you intuition for what to expect
with week's election for example you
don't expect if you do have these um
power-law mutation kernels you expect to
probably be able to see that with week's
election and if there's something we can
learn about that from this model even
when we're applying it to real data for
example this gene expression data that's
almost certainly under week's election
that might be a good thing and of course
it's a null model you need to when
you're saying that some quantitative
trait has evolved under selection it's
usually a good idea to know what you
mean by saying a quantum trait hasn't
developed in your selection thanks
it's a lot of time for questions okay
he's give a quick intuition for what
exactly is going wrong in the heavy tail
case of sample size you're a bigger
sample sizes there's some very large
event usually share those to it yeah I
think that's basically what's going
wrong is that sort of even in the limit
you get such mark mutations and each
locus lat you that you get some extra
correlation structure exactly can you
put up the tribe area yeah right so this
guy is that's a stable guy right now
though so this is got give you sort of
come across the stuff about la posh
representation don't think so so
basically if you've got some any stable
you can write it as a an infinite series
of iid random variables with weights
sort of one's a gamma gammas to the
minus alpha you know gamma random
variables that minus alpha and so you
know those by a deep random variable
sort of tells you kind of what the story
is so translating and it's sort of
similar also into this that you can you
know right this characteristic function
in turn
a distribution on the great unit speed
right and so either of those things so
if you were feeling for sort of what's
going on I randomly just something one
is give us a field yeah it's clean up
but you know trying those things I think
it just sort of seemed not to disagree
with my court there's also a plus on
representation for these things to show
you the stable all comes from mostly a
few more erotic dream and when the large
values are shared between the linage
rights monitors over that's what the
lavage representation does oh yeah I
mean it's a rewriting of the the labor
union oh awesome story where you sort of
group things in such a way that and so
it really gives you a sense of you know
you're stable you know it's sort of just
like with a Gaussian sort of you that's
doing something similar to giving you
the ellipsoid associated with the
variance covariance matrix sort of
telling you know most of the actions
happening in this direction these are
photo Titans be
yeah we're cleaning there so so you can
you scribed it and this is not a log
scale so saying you know you go back a
million year there's not much of it
suddenly my new years well they're
claiming is basically and I don't fully
agree with their interpretation of it
but what they're claiming is that it
basically wait it's sort of a stasis
followed by rapid evolution model so I
lucky why are we actually looking at
here nope what uh i would so this so
this axis is the divergence in these log
in log scale divergence and this axis is
time right between two contento think
this is from fossil taxa so that time
six eyes sighs yeah I forget exactly we
have time I chose one of the like five
of these figures from the paper so I
don't remember which which phenotype it
is but I mean they basically say okay
well we have these pair of fossils that
are 10 to the four years apart their
body size is also is this much
difference fought back and then so on
and so forth but is there if you had
this but the smallest out of this some
comparison curve that you could come
there that you would unambiguously
expect with the brain story right yeah
and then
yeah I mean I beretta actually I mean so
what they did was they tried to fit a
you know Brian motion kind of thing to
this and then they also fit sort of a
one-hit compound poisson process so
there's all sort of condition to go off
only once and they said the likelihood
hit the that's a wednesday i think it's
the variance expected variance under
that best fit model so what they really
really like it's sort of stasis with
some wine noise and then one hit of a
Poisson process that send you going to
find so when you showed us your
calculation for the characteristic
function yeah it means that you have
integrated over the year
prostitution of the truth yeah and so
the tree chosen to scare you have an
integrated at the prior you've taken and
the infinitely many copies of the prior
right but for each one an integrated
okay that's sort of this is it my tree
free reason yeah this lesson is going on
here in the sample of size 2 is on first
conditioning on the tree and then I've
integrated okay because I don't know
anything about it so what computers do
you have the fact that you think human
corazon for let's see nautically yeah so
I'm actually imagining this being within
a population rather than becoming
species so I'm sort of thinking over
here sorry bidding get me to say this
one you've been degraded over the very
but in the tribe area where I also
integrated over image about what you do
is you take samples of the tree then run
your stable thing on that and then at
all of those guys up right right that's
house anyway yes so you're getting so
from that you you're having a just
adding up lots of mixtures of stables
right but ending up with something
that's stable with the end right that's
kind of a cool thing where are you
adding them up very long it did careful
no you're anything I don't you oh yeah
I'm actually adding across their trees
Chris your quantitative trait is the sum
of all these contributions from usual
okis things as a call lesson with
innocence ease within a population so
it's not like
look they share the same ancestors yeah
yeah you have a different color lesson
for each one person in the pelvis it's
modern so that's the cool thing you're
adding up all these some these mixtures
of stables of multivariate stables and
getting a multivariate stable in the end
or not well know that whenever I very
the guy is a stable it is the stable
well I'll catch you think three more
questions here as I think so one
application of your state of work is in
the contrast between june and wide
Association study searches and the
genome-wide complex trait modeling come
on could you and the GCT a approach
originally implemented starts off with
that Gaussian distribution track
critical to it if you change that to a
stable distribution you presumably get
quite different answers could you say a
few words about how you see the
implications of this contrast for
practical article complex trait analysis
yeah sort of thought about that
peripheral a month I I do think that the
the data points to some things like
height really being pretty Gaussian
benefit the distribution in population
is pretty Gaussian and when you do G
wash you to get these Gaussian things I
think the place I really think gene
expression is really one of the key
places where you might see this kind of
stable law because of things like
knocking out transcription factor
binding sites for school and I think
that you
you'll still get a signal of that when
people do like a G wass for eqtls
expression cutie else because you will
pick up for example like you often pick
up like that there's tons of cysts like
very local regulatory variation that is
very large effect compared to any of the
the transacting variation that you can
find and part of that is a power issue
because you're doing much fewer tests
when you're looking insist but I do
think that that I think we'll get hints
of it if this is really going on into
human traits are in traits are we really
take power to do you also will start to
see inside why well if I just plot the
empirical distribution of effect sizes
that I see even though I've made
conferred this under a Gaussian
assumption I'll start to see that maybe
there's too much large tailed stuff that
and I would have expected even though
I'm giving sort of you know thinking
about in a sort of an empirical things
kind of way you're going to see that
your empirical bayes assumption that
really fit in the end you make just two
quick questions and answers ladies I had
one party related to that so one of the
substance I understood is not easy
week's election is in relation to
generation time so you need to have
strong selection in respect to
generation plan for it or something that
like years bridging the generation time
of the protein is quite longer than the
division time off of the years the early
can easily see but related Kent's
question in terms of the application of
some other critters with quantitative
traitor there i think i agree with you
it would be very intriguing to see if it
really fits when it comes down to G Wars
or gene expression data I'm always
to go because like our our detection our
screening on small defects is so limited
the face by the method set we we will
lose a lot on it and it might easily
look like that you don't find the small
effects and it looks not at all guys
should because of the methods involved
or not because of the day that right
like that and now as there is this
figure assured the inferred this okay
well this thing and what this paper was
about was taking my conferred effect
distribution which is obviously going to
be biased for large effects and back
inferring what the small one facts sort
of things look like so yeah and and I do
think that this probably reasonable for
things like so one thing about the gene
expression data is the first educational
course is in a particular place assists
reporting which open potentially has a
limited
right so i presume that complicates how
I think about quitting distribution I
think it does and yeah I mean I realized
that too in service and I don't know
what exactly would do so you could
imagine that sort of the transifex give
you a gaussian next sort of fall into
the gaussian thing and then you add this
one additional genealogy that gives you
a large effect thing and so in principle
it's easy to to do these calculations
and see how much you know how much
having a whole bunch of learning in fact
mutations matters versus just happening
really one place and I don't have an
intuition for how much okay no that's